uh from timcast.com youtube to remove
videos containing false claims and
unsafe instructions regarding abortion
quote we prioritize connecting people to
content from authoritative sources on
health topics now this is interesting
this is censorship about false claims
and unsafe instructions regarding
abortion
is that actually
helping
conservatives no no think about it
the vice magazine vice their website
published an article on taking horse
medicine to induce abortion oh yeah
that's right what cute yes
i thought we're supposed to be against
horses that's what i was going to say
only a pure road
joe rogan says it we are against
horsemen are we against
[Laughter]
and it's called the uh horse it's called
the horseshoe uh medicine theory and
it's uh it's on the right it's iromatic
on the left it's i forgot what it's
called you guys know what it's called
yeah it's like an antibiotic no it was
like an antacid or something or i don't
know induces abortion and then in the
middle was bojack horseman but it's like
vice actually ran that so think about
what's happening right now you've got
red states banning abortion youtube
enacts a censorship policy that's going
to stop progressives and liberals from
giving advice on how to induce abortion
or seek it out in these states
wow so that's actually so maybe
youtube's kind of against the baby
killing or where are we going i think
youtube's always been scared of
liability they should be that's it so
that's why when you get claims from
they're right about say from acting
they're like no no shut it down shut it
down because someone would sue them now
you've got progressives who are going to
be like here's how you induce an
abortion and they're like no no no shut
it down shut it down
yeah but this is where corporate
communism comes in i'm very much against
censorship so
you know what's really amazing is i
believe in people and i believe in their
intelligence and i believe if you allow
them if they can read as much as they
can and see and see people debate and
argue and share ideas guess what people
are going to figure out the truth
so so let's let's take this
what if youtube didn't censor all that
stuff and they're put and i you know how
pro-life i am and you have them people
putting out stories about how to
self-induce an abortion which i think is
horrific they die
they would die
it's it's awful but then you would also
have people trying to save their lives
on youtube saying this this will kill
you don't do this it's not going to just
kill your baby it's going to kill you
and and you so i suppose the issue is i
mean we don't want anyone to take a a
drug and and kill themselves and that's
horrific but then that's an extreme
example but when you allow people to
debate ideas and sort of cover it up
yeah you know what it's the truth is
gonna get revealed so i totally agree
with you on that free speech point
that's why free speech is so important
to debate the real ideas um i'm still in
shock that me and you went for the same
horse joke at the same time and i'm like
damn it now we are friends um and then
the other thing i really like i'm gonna
stop all the rumors about me jamie this
is that that's my goal
that is my goal that's awesome um the
the other thing i liked that you said
was
the anti-war comment because to me
being truly pro-life is
pro-life if you're if you're pro-life
when it comes to abortion you in my
opinion pro-life is also anti-death
penalty it's anti-war it's you know all
these things it's a stance on abortion
no no no but like if you're taking it as
a bigger uh a bigger picture no because
i think that's what about ism because
it's like oh you're pro-life well what
about this social issue i
i hold dear to me and this one and this
one and this one and if you don't agree
with me on all of those
well then you're not pro-life are you
well i take back my one compliment
margery uh no i no i i really do think
that like if you take it out of an
abortion context right so you could flip
it the other way only in the abortion
context we we at timcast.com had an
editorial meaning and we do not use to
the best of our abilities we uh refrain
from using the terms pro-choice and
pro-life in these in these contexts
because it does not adequately explain
what's happening in many of these
protests so there were a bunch of
protests some people were out there
being like we're pro-choice yeah and
it's like what does that mean because
all that results in is like you got
people who are who are for a vax mandate
and then the inverse argument happens
well if you're really for pro-choice
then you have to support my right not to
take medicaid medication and the left
doesn't do it right and then the left
says well if you were really pro-life
and then i'm like it doesn't matter
right are you for abortion or do you
oppose abortion sure the the pro-choice
group was actually advocating for the
expansion of abortion and the right
group was arguing for the
rescinding of access or i should say a
reduction in access to abortion so we
just say pro and anti-abortion cool i
will rephrase i like that you're
anti-war and i am i am anti-war i like
that a lot and i think a lot of people
on the left probably don't know that
especially as the left is advocating for
war my question on abortion and i mean
this like it's not a gotcha thing like i
legitimately want to know is if abortion
was banned when you were talking about
those youtube videos and obviously women
would get hurt right if they try to
induce their own abortion because you're
watching i can barely learn a song on
guitar watching youtube tutorials let
alone am i going gonna figure out how to
perform an abortion uh which would be
awful it would not be good so my
question they don't want anybody to do
that one should do that what do you do
like what is your
solution for those cases and i i don't
care about percentages let's say it's
one for those case of
a child being rape for the for the case
of incest is what is the answer because
i don't know right what's the answer for
what happens a lot of times with
prohibition where it's still going to
happen but it's going to happen unsafe
like
what do we do about those situations if
because i do believe that you're
pro-life for like i believe that you
well there's a really it's a really
simple argument because we've had this
conversation like 50 billion times
um banning murder you still have murders
so right so if the idea is that an
abortion is wrong and it's a murder and
people decide to go and just try and
commit it in an unsafe way it's like
that's gonna happen no but i i i just
wanna know because you did make that
point about how you want to help women
as well so like what would you do if
abortion was legal to help those women
well tim just made a really good point
we murder is illegal and people are
getting murdered every day
so and we can't we don't have a perfect
world and it's impossible to control
everything and stop anything bad from
happening to anyone we wish we could
but it's impossible right
so
and and a child being raped incest is
wrong all of that stuff are horrific and
occasionally they happen
and so that's why there's some people
have different levels of what they think
is right and wrong for abortion i still
believe in life at conception i really
do
and then on rape
now this is what happens when a woman is
raped and if she goes to the hospital
right away they typically give her a
plan b pill that happens
almost in every single instance when a
woman goes to the hospital and there's
an extensive uh process for the woman to
be treated
so that is like it's such a small
percentage real quick does plan plan b
prevents conception
plan b prevents uh prevents implantation
and i'm not saying i'm for that i'm just
saying that's what happens when women
are raped are someone informed that
they're given that pill yes they are
informed when they go to the hospital
that they're given that pill
so just letting you know how rare it is
if a woman is really raped and she goes
to the hospital for it
i think most women are taking it um but
there's also some amazing stories oh my
gosh you meet some of the most beautiful
people and hear their stories that were
born out of rape and
and and wow those are some strong women
to to give to to have that child
that was born out of a horrible horrible
situation but i will say this
abortion was not legal
until what was it 1973 yeah so imagine
how many people have lived
during the since the beginning of time
because there weren't abortions well and
that's why whenever you get people on
the left who sound like they're
pro-abortion not the safe rare and legal
but just like you know all willy-nilly
about it like i i'm never gonna be on
that
side the reason that the word choice for
me is so important is because
of those rare circumstances you know
what i mean and that's where i just go
it's so hard for me to fully commit over
to the other side when you hear you know
terrible stories about things that
happen to you know kids and then you
just go ah
i don't know it's so hard it's so hard i
i
i think it's absolutely insane that
we've gotten to the point where there's
advocacy for
uh post-viability abortion
because oh yeah elective
contraceptive post-viability abortion to
me just sounds like
insane it is insane you mean you can
deliver the baby it can be c-section you
can induce labor and the baby can live
but you want to kill it anyway uh that's
just i'm sorry oh it's too much it's
it's it's like it's such a thing you
can't even comprehend it but really
you you to i think we forgot i think so
many people have forgotten that before
1973 there was an abortion and and we've
s over 63 million people have been
killed in the womb and you have to ask
who are those people who would they have
been isn't it how would of our how would
our society be different if they were
here with us what if they were all the
bad people
five times more likely to be black
i believe i believe it's five times more
like truly black genocide it's
absolutely insane to me and just awful
the way that you can have the
conversation i think is so important
where it's just we are lacking empathy
right
it's either you are
pro-women dying or pro-babies dying
if you just look at it on twitter or
facebook or whatever and i think just
having that second when you hear a story
and this is with all issues not even
just abortion when there's a school
shooting
everyone i we don't live in a world
anymore or when a tragedy happens we can
all
take a deep breath and actually feel
empathy for the people who were actually
hurt or for the woman who was raped or
for you know all these stories we
immediately have to go what is our side
saying how can we blame the republicans
how can we blame the democrats and
that's where i think we're losing our
soul i got i got to tell you you know as
someone who's been traditionally liberal
and pro-choice i do not see that from
the right i see no i'm saying in general
but but i don't i don't hear uh it's the
democrats fault how can we blame them i
hear you like like i i put you know what
let me see if i can pull something up on
instagram yeah let me let me pull up the
old tim cast instagram i think was the
last thing i posted
all right is it gonna give me the
business let's see if i can uh
i'll get it all right here we go take a
look at this okay let's go so
we show this all the time the ground
news bias mine is is left leaning but
there's a 30 percent right
anger sargon of newsweek actually more
right wing than left wing and then we
have ben shapiro 39 left 48 right and
then you have the nbc news team just all
completely left i don't hear that
when it's like there's an argument
happening the right says
guys let's let's figure this out let's
compromise and the left just says you're
far right and crazy and i won't listen
to you especially after roe was
overturned think about all of these
pro-life advocacy groups and crisis
pregnancy centers that were getting
targeted after that i feel like that's
all being perpetrated by the left and by
pro-abortionists
elizabeth warren wants to to shut yeah
they want to literally ban this this is
a senator she thinks they don't have the
right to exist in these pregnancy
resources
i volunteered at one of them and they
had fake appointments booked all the
time by these pro-choicers who wanted to
sabotage the purpose of that place which
is all volunteer-based so by the way can
i tell you
as uh a dude on the left
what i heard about those places so i
know nothing about those places straight
up like i i would ask you who worked
there um but what we heard on the left
all i knew
was essentially oh those are the places
that trick girls who want to get
abortions and pressure them into having
the baby that's like the talking point
there's nothing
no no but like that's yeah they like
give carriages and like formula and they
help them sign up for government
services free ultrasound free ultrasound
free resources free counseling the
counseling monsters as framed as like
we're gonna trick you into not getting
an abortion there were plenty of clients
who walked out all the time saying like
no i think i'm still going to get an
abortion and they were like okay and
then you tied them down
like we can't stop you but like we can't
stop people we can lock these doors they
were like we actually have this room
here you can stay in the doors lock for
night nine months
[Laughter]
that does not happen
no but i mean but but this is what i'm
talking about right where it's like
and i'm sure by the way
there are pro-choice people who would
make points i hope about sex education
or about things like that that maybe you
guys would agree with or maybe pro-life
people would agree with and when i hear
what those centers really are i go okay
man well i guess i was wrong about that
and i just wish we could have more
conversations like this where it's like
the goal should be less suffering period
whether that's for babies whether that's
for women and then you take people who
disagree and you go how do we get this i
agree and you want to know something yes
i enjoy you being in this conversation
because i think men should be in the
conversation because you want to know
something being a father is also so
important
what and why don't men get a sec about
the choices why has it taken me since 40
years old to hang out with conservative
women this rules
that's right i am important you guys
hear that follow me on twitter
[Laughter]
well i wonder if a lot of what we see
with you know look it's like two-thirds
70 of millennial females are democrat
voters
so i wonder how many of those guys are
just like whatever you say i'll say
whatever i have to say to hook up with
you right i don't know but i passed by a
whole table full of them last night in a
restaurant
and i have to tell you i gotta tell you
guys what happened
so we're in this restaurant we got there
they had a little american flags on the
sidewalk i was like i think i'm going to
be safe here
so
we're hanging out have a great time but
we're walking out and we're walking by
the patio and there's a large table of
yeah millennial-aged women
and what tipped you off to them was
there when you saw them were you like oh
no i wasn't like oh it was they were
like and they're like
she's horrible oh my god i can't believe
that's mtg blah blah blah blah
and i was like oh boy here we go and
then they started they were throwing the
names and making the comments so i just
turned around to him and i said hey
thanks for voting for biden
our the inflation it's great gas prices
i can't afford them thank you guys are
doing awesome your president he's the
best you guys did great
and they were like ah they're yelling at
me and i said i hope you all have babies
i hope you all have babies i can't wait
you should be a mom everybody be a
mother have a baby
and then i left and then oh that they
were unglued the fact that your heckle
line is i hope you have a baby is so
funny to me it's what hits home for
those women the most right city living
late i just want to write a blog i don't
want to have a baby
no i just want them to be happy
they're so bitter because they but think
about how they're targeted though they
they were encouraged to have a career
and then the company they work for is
probably some corporation or a big one
like the federal government because it
was in washington dc oh boy yeah and but
think about this what are what are
corporations doing right now paying for
abortions abortion vacation
parental leave too yeah but you want to
know what's more difficult for the
employer
that that that maternity leave yeah yeah
dealing with those them missing to go to
all their doctor's appointments so we we
uh a couple things one is apparently
companies that are doing that are
getting sued because men say it's a
discriminatory practice to offer a
benefit to only females yeah but uh oh
yeah i should get a vacation just to
knock people out no no no the idea is
this if he's going to try to balance a
guy oh jamie sorry sorry a guy should be
able to go to the company and say i
think i got a woman pregnant and she
needs an abortion so pay for it and they
should have to do that as well
otherwise it's a discriminatory practice
to only pay for abortion services for
female employees so are you into
depopulation is that what's going on
here this sounds very world economical
here at tim cast
we will not pay for our female employees
abortions we'll give them unlimited
maternity and paternity leave for the
men because we trust the people who work
here legitimately want to work here and
if they need time with their children
they're allowed to have it all right
well i guess that l.a trip i told you
about next week is off
well i'm not paying for abortion
services but if you have a kid go take
care of your kid and we'll let us know
when you're when you're good so uh it's
like we have a big company but we do
have you know a lot of employees and
then family issues have come up and i'm
like take as much time as you need
i i trust that the job you do is
something you're passionate about and if
you're not then maybe you shouldn't be
here anyway
so just go go do your thing and then
we'll figure it out and then
if we don't hear from him for a couple
weeks i'll be like how are you how's it
going let us know when you're ready
i think you know maybe it's too trusting
a lot of big corporations don't want to
do that because they don't trust their
employees and a lot of employees
probably would would exploit that but
i don't know i will say stupid the care
you have for us is insane
that's very he he also i i will also say
he doesn't take compliments well um
don't get mushy don't you tell me i care
about my empire oh my god
[Applause]
he only locked you in there for nine
months yeah nine months yeah that was
that was the rule uh i i i give you
bacon tim tim will text me like really
good news like hey we're going to do
this and i will write him the sappiest
response where i'm just like this has
been a dream of mine and i've been
through so much and then his response is
just like she had five i'm like
okay okay there's a lot of that it's a
lot of that thanks for checking out this
clip from timcast irl come hang out live
monday through friday at 8 pm eastern
time super chat we'll even answer some
of your questions if you want to check
out the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you